all right is that focused I think so
hope so good um I haven't got long it is
the end of the day I'm losing the light
I've got to drive on and then catch a
flight arts in so I'm gonna tell you the
story but I have not been able to work
out how much of it is true and that's
okay and I'll tell you why that's okay
but it does put me in a bit of a
difficult position because everyone will
not have met here in Wichita Falls Texas
has been lovely and this is a great
story that sends tourists there town so
with that said this is the newbie
McMahon building the world's littlest
skyscraper it's not much of a skyscraper
it's only four storeys tall and it's
footprint is so small that it is very
usable as a building now the legend goes
that back when Wichita Falls was an oil
boomtown 1918 there was a massive
construction rush investors were pouring
money into new downtown buildings
confident that the town would be prime
real estate for decades to come
unfortunately it wasn't the boom was
followed by a bust and by the Great
Depression but this building calls its
investors more trouble than most it cost
two hundred thousand dollars which is
about three million in today's money and
the investors thought that it was going
to be 12 times as tall because the
blueprints they thought were marked in
feet were actually in inches no one
noticed a little extra mark next to
numbers on the plans so the new downtown
skyscraper turned out to be only four
storeys tall not 48 and so narrow it was
almost unusable the developer JD McMahon
ran off with most of the money all that
was left over from only having to
construct a tiny building and local
judge ruled that the blueprints were
accurate the investors had got exactly
what they'd signed off on exactly what
they paid for the building sat abandoned
for a long time it was renovated in the
early 21st century in these days it's a
furniture boutique and I talked to the
owner when we first took over this
building with our shop this skyscraper
was never allowed to be entered by the
public and we wanted to open it up the
engineers had to come to make sure that
the floors could sustain constant
occupancy and in fact they did have to
give us some weight and load limits and
they did have to put in an additional
structural beam whenever you have a
multi-story building by city code there
must be an egress and an entrance so
they have
said well we must have at least two
staircases to allow for that well if
this building had two sets of stairs it
would literally be a building full of
two sets of stairs and there would be no
defined space whatsoever so I think as
the compromise from our city we do have
state-of-the-art fire suppression system
the fire marshal that comes to inspect
it periodically he tells me that if we
do ever catch on fire we will not have
to worry about burning but we might have
to worry about drowning in the early 30s
this was engulfed in flames and so the
floors were gone the roof was gone and
it got boarded up and it stood that way
for decades we do have some old
newspaper accounts and some old
documentation of people that were
interviewed back then how they wanted
the building to be demolished
immediately because it was a scandal you
know these people had been ripped off
and they were embarrassed about being
duped like this however it wasn't
demolished because they really needed it
for office space so it was used so we do
have some documentation like that but
the original plans that allegedly he had
given to his investors they don't exist
as far as I know it's a great story so I
start to fact-check it and I came up
blank here's what I did before getting
here I tracked down every article I
could on every database I could access
but they were all too modern and the
chain of references ran out usually
somewhere in the 80s there are
references to a Ripley's Believe It or
Not panel from the 1920s but I email the
archivists at Ripley's and they said
their archives are incomplete they don't
have a copy of it no one has a copy of
it and look if we're honest Ripley's
Believe It or Not is not a reliable
primary source so when I got here I went
to the Wichita Falls library over there
thank you so much to all the librarians
who helped and I looked through the
local newspaper from 1919 it's not been
digitized so I had to hunt through
microfilm and scan headlines and in the
time I had here I couldn't find a
mention of the building or of the
lawsuit at all I did find an article
about the changing skyline it has no
mention of a planned 48 storey building
so it feels like the real estate scanner
a lawsuit after should have been all
over the news when it came out surely
but maybe I missed it maybe it was too
small an article in Boone
times it might have been or maybe I
wasn't looking at the right date and
look this is a ridiculous building on
camera it almost looks sensible but
standing here it is very easy to agree
that this building must have been a scam
of some sort so if I was to place a bet
I would say the scam part is likely the
fact that someone came along in the
middle of boom times sold a dodgy
building too gullible investors and ran
off with the proceeds is very very
plausible the inches instead of feet
detail of the story though I just don't
know surely the investors would have
noticed that a giant skyscraper only had
four floors and a couple of windows
surely they'd have questioned the plans
so maybe that was a joke from the town's
folk a century ago that got reported as
fact
or maybe the investors were often in
other state and never got a closer look
at the blueprints or maybe it's true and
they were taken in by a smooth-talking
scammer there is a plausible answer that
every skeptics question about this and I
am NOT saying that the story is false
just that I can't find foreign resources
I can't find anything from the time that
is evidence for it or against it and if
you can don't tell me right now at all I
post some are authoritative taking a
picture of the old newspaper and tweeted
out update Wikipedia I've reached the
end of what I can do but that's fine and
here's why it's fine because this is
folklore this is a trickster story this
is the same thing that appears in
mythology from around the world and
across time if you think you've heard
something like this before you have
there are a lot of stories like it it's
the monorail episode of The Simpsons all
those news outlets and blogs repeating
and emphasizing the tale that's our
modern oral tradition that's passing on
stories person to person to person in a
world where making up complete lies to
get ad revenue is a viable business
model this is kind of charming it's a
story and as long as those articles say
according to legend or the tale goes
that then I think that's fine we're
human we see things as part of a
narrative Margaret Atwood wrote in the
end will all become stories and yeah
this is a really good story
all right I hope that worked because
I've got um well not enough time to get
to Dallas all right let's go
you